[Music]
in festival fail news submitted by it's
me it'sa me Mario
but the worst festival in history went
from being a hilarious fail to an FBI
investigation would though I hear
nothing but worse and worse and worse er
and the worst is [ __ ] coming from his
[ __ ] bus and then the FBI is involved
that is that really was it like the
festival of dick because that's a pretty
bad festival and you guys heard the fire
festival no ja Rule was promoting this
murder I kinda heard a ja rule in a long
time yes I thought 50 destroyed his
career yet he's doesn't exist anymore is
it even gonna work if ja rule promote
something I know like how many followers
yes that's kind of like Steve Urkel's
like yo come down to this [ __ ]
big-ass party you know what now I would
go to Steve Urkel's here Steve Urkel I
like Steve Urkel
yo how did how did 50 cent ruined Ja
Rule's career again I can't remember all
right if you haven't seen 50s biopic
that character that's a fake rapper
gangster it's actually ja Rule I haven't
seen it so happens well he is a poser
and a fake thug and 50 does not like
that and I think he was a I don't know
like he was being a notorious fever or
like his gang affiliations and mm-hmm of
the same area and I think he like
pretended to be someone that was very
close to 50 or whatever it was and then
he just said uh-uh if he is not right
we're shocked to do I don't know about
Ashanti but this was maybe guilty by
association I might not be telling it a
hundred percent correct all I know is 50
did not like the ja Rule because he's a
studio gangster oh and that's like back
in the day when your street cred was
like Earth Day but it was personal 250
though it wasn't okay she was in
Persinger's friend yeah was something
like that it wasn't like it wasn't like
mad on like this guy just because he's a
wannabe it's more like
something about his group and personal
[ __ ] that Pacific I shot so many times
dude that was a cat
he's a gang she doesn't want to die no
it's Mar da I always thought Java was a
[ __ ] check this out my friend booked
him at a club
so my friends pretty short right and he
was like Ja Rule's shorter than him
dang whoa and I was like really I knew
he was a [ __ ] could be shuffle they
started height what a [ __ ] I know
something about him like his music
sometimes it was cool so I'll be in the
car like yeah man is pretty cool I still
don't like him something about him he's
lying to me maybe I felt his [ __ ]
lying this on the through the music what
was the song about super popular no no
no no no no yo Lee today sister I anon
not gonna notice I like it's a it's a
remake up someone else's life at home
man Kevin listen you wonder yeah it is
but that was ja Rule yeah Jon rule and
like like I know your life sorrow I
thought he was [ __ ] black see you
sense it too didn't you
you sensed a lying sack of [ __ ] [ __ ]
through the music how you gonna be
[ __ ] gangstas talking about lost
farms all day no I just didn't like the
fact that his first music video that
went huge he was wearing a red bandana
the exact same way he trying to be too
far I hated that [ __ ] when I saw I was
like you are not Tupac I woulda liked
him hip-hop but I like to pause out like
this anyway ja Rule was promoting this
oh he partnered up with this guy this 25
year old man named Billy mcFarland
and so Billy apparently he's like a
buddy got [ __ ] up a lot just an
entrepreneur exactly he's started many
businesses that apparently he failed
that most of them are like he left
investors like what the [ __ ]
so partnering overdraw role to start a
tech company so it's called a smart oh
it was an app they were building an app
to allow people to bid for a celebrity
to appear at their event that's what the
app was for oh that's pretty cool that
is kind of cool let's call it a fire app
very cool sorry guys
there's like Bella Hadid in it and like
other models nothing this video and
they're just promoting this lady's
daughter see sister Christian here we go
in the bus and games pizza but that way
and also death high is when I get there
okay now here this is is land there's no
wrong way though it's on the other side
hobby gets a little tiny plane whether
it goes on all and it's like a duck yeah
like a helicopter everything that
they're showing in this video according
to the lawsuit wasn't at all what they
were gonna provide force
[Applause]
ya know water looks nice
you know that's a lie
that's our rule
I need to know where that island is the
best in food art and music whoa
owned by Papa what the island was once
owned by Pablo Escobar
this was fun and all the functions a
bunch of hot girls all me and nice water
just not true what else is that it does
look fun
I think it's mainly the hot girls in the
night more there's no giant because it
was like 20
I dunno lies yet I don't want to go
there I still would go 20 hit a runway
20 other girls equals one hot girl okay
no way that was a 20 ugly girl is better
than 20 ugly guys there but that's what
I'm saying though how come like in these
videos how come is only enticed towards
men like the women I want to go to these
things cause I want to be like the women
that they see so they don't have to can
all thinking like if people draw this
big dicks all Billy McFarlane he does
not look twenty [ __ ] five he looks
like a good forty three it's because all
the people that he cheated stresses
amount so much money I don't think you
like more like 37 they ended up selling
8,000 tickets to this thing the tickets
were ranging from 1,000 to 12,000 holy
Sh and they kept promising like all
these extravagant things that none of it
you know a thousand to two thousand
dollars isn't that crazy for that
because like VIP hotel tickets are about
like that much $2,000 they're expensive
but distance but this is their entries a
thousand of 12 thousand thirty IP is
twelve thousand I heard a thousand to
two thousand so you should have found
well okay well alright that means
they're nosebleeds is a thousand dollars
is it twelve thousand for like a whole
weekend or like one day I'm not sure but
I'm assuming if it's like a like
Coachella or whatever and it's like a
whole weekend I can kind of see VAP
being twelve thousand because you're
going to a private island they were
selling packages for $400,000 never mind
saying that this was the artists Palace
and it would have four beds eight VIP
tickets and you would be able to have a
dinner with one of the performers at the
event and so the headliner was blink-182
they cancelled on the event because they
were not prepared for this event at all
so there was no plumbing no type of
structures at all of it was it's
literally just the island yeah I wasn't
it was a desert I was you need like a
bill
in dollars develop it and they were
promising like luxury meals being having
new so they showed up and they're like I
gotta plug my app in somewhere to play
actually we don't have any electricity
and I just can't hold right before that
yeah they didn't even show up
so blink-182 they did have their
equipment sent there but because of the
event owing so much money every
direction they can't release Raquin a to
the equipment to them because they owe
fees the customs fees or like the event
owes customs oh my god oh we're going to
be naming it their equipment and there's
just one hot mess of a festival so much
ism you're killed so here's the video
clip of what it looked like when people
actually got there oh my god people I
think pain I feel so bad for damn I am
yeah hundreds of people arrived at the
island they were just stranded there
because there was no lights there was
nowhere to sleep like no like crappy
crappy food and they're just horrible
they should have just made a video there
and made a real one
and in there like straight up castaways
and [ __ ] Oh more like Lord in this
life no turn into survivor so this is
like a real quick save is Olly Murs
nobody there hop in - there's no one
whoa what is the supermodel who's got
one guy in the yellow shirt not only
that but this island must be they were
on that's good because people can't even
get in the water because it was near
shark-infested waters oh my goodness is
that it that that's the crowd right
there yeah
oh no there's more to does talking are
these lockers that it looks like a
[ __ ] janky as a [ __ ]
yeah so people reported that whoever put
their stuff in there it actually got
broken into and stolen oh my god lost
their stuff
this is the food that was given log
sorry but I steal that from jail is that
just bread cheese and salad - yeah
that's it what the [ __ ] dude and here's
the country it has the audacity to still
go through with it
and so they were saying that contractors
were letting the event organizers know
like we're nowhere near ready for this
event that happen
they still linked it with it and when
tickets were already being sold they
still didn't even have an island at that
time when the tickets were being bought
like what that's right I hope this is no
joke - 25 year-old - really bad for say
this I hope gets murdered because like
he is a [ __ ] scalping like you are a
terrible human being
what happens is y'all rule we have a
manatee this is intense that a luxury
tent a luxury tension looks like a
[ __ ] refugee area bucket like that
term i ting my homes or some [ __ ] yeah
and they're [ __ ] with people that got
money exactly so that was the funny
thing so then they were saying like well
why would you screw over people that are
willing to pay this much because
obviously they're gonna be willing to
pay for lawyers to through your ass no
there's multiple lawsuits that have came
out of this and there's even like a
class-action lawsuit for all the people
that I got affected - they were telling
people that this event was going to be a
cashless event so they had to put money
into the bracelets for the fire festival
so then people put so no one got refund
they just jacked them exactly and so
employee of the fire employees are
saying that they use that money that
they took from the bracelets to pay out
like a lot of their debts that they had
over this festival not only that but
Billy there was this a leak conversation
with the employees that he's telling
them like a guy so you're not going to
get paid for the last two weeks don't
expect you to get a paycheck but we're
not firing you
we're just not going to pay you so then
the employees are like oh so you're not
going to fire us so we can't even claim
unemployment benefit but you're not
going to pay us either so we just have
to sit here in total or some years like
what the [ __ ]
so it's just this gesture where did you
where is he I'm not sure what the [ __ ]
it sucks because I bet you like Joel was
like yeah I'll do it
I just put my name on it and promote it
and he probably doesn't know anything
email is going on or in the in the
process or he knew I don't know about
the process but afterwards every when
everyone found
when she might have known right maybe
swap it there's still planning for next
year's fire I mean ja Rule said the
whole world knows fires name now this
will Pat guide the whole world knows
that it was a [ __ ] fire [ __ ] thank
you so stupid I think John was really
good at planning stuff you know what
though I I just [ __ ] hate event
organizers like this because this
happened to us too what which taught us
a big [ __ ] lesson Oh when you guys
were in Australia right no it happened
we got we got paid for that partially
but um at least we didn't lose money but
the thing is out here we did a whole
show it was us dumbfounded and turns out
a ghetto tank but it was one of those
things that's like oh you're gonna do it
okay we'll do it too and all these
things we have warning signs but we
didn't really like say no because we you
know all these other people are doing it
so let's just [ __ ] go
what were the warning signs though like
one he didn't pay the deposit for
anybody
Oh - he's a straight [ __ ] amateur
he's never done this before but he
talked a big game three he works at a
mattress store not talking [ __ ] about
people who work at mattress stores but
if you're trying to pull off a big event
and you're promising all this cash to a
lot of people usually people that work
at mattress stores don't have $40,000
laying around that's crazy that that
that should have been like a dog what
the [ __ ] yeah even the fire festival
lawyers started sending the cease and
desist letters to attendees that we're
posting about this festival thing so the
defendants claim that they could incite
violence writing or civil unrest and
with the caveat that if someone innocent
does get hurt of the results fire
festival will hold you accountable and
we can't do anybody proceed you have no
[ __ ] money you have there's no
it's so hilarious that they're even
trying to stop the spread of the truth
their whole team is a lots of lawyers or
liabilities laughs how masuo is dog
we're going to [ __ ] tell the truth
we didn't even go to this event but [ __ ]
you guys you can't give him a
cease-and-desist if they didn't agree to
any of that [ __ ] talking about
seasoned is my [ __ ] nuts [ __ ] this
is like one of the worst cases of false
advertising I've ever seen yeah that
[ __ ] trailer was amazing yeah and
then the actual game looked like like I
don't even like half that [ __ ] I don't
like all those crazy lights and noise
the women were fantastic but I wanted to
be there like I wanted to see underwater
booty that's a [ __ ] like a mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] these guys hello my mother
Joe Malians please like the video and
for more beautiful videos look up there
[Music]
you